bienvenido hablemos de la web esto que
estás usando justo ahora la web es una
gran red de computadoras conectadas y
para 2014 había literalmente más de 1000
millones de sitios web
mil millones cuando yo era pequeña solo
había un millón y pensábamos que era
muchísimo para que usamos los sitios web
bueno en el principio los investigadores
usaban los sitios web para compartir su
trabajo como el colisionador de
partículas de alta energía pero en la
actualidad todos lo usan para casi
cualquier cosa como las redes sociales
para platicar con la familia un sitio
web de fotos para compartir las fotos de
tu hermoso gatito un sitio web de viajes
para planear unas vacaciones exóticas o
un sitio web de noticias para ponerte al
día con lo que pasa en el mundo y por
supuesto debes estar usando el sitio web
de khan academy para aprender así que
cuál es tu sitio web favorito
en realidad tengo una pregunta mejor qué
sitio web te gustaría que existiera pero
todavía no lo hay
tal vez un sitio web de ti mismo o de
algo que te gusta mucho lo interesante
de esto es que tú puedes programar un
sitio web y puedes aprender a hacerlo
aquí en can academy empieza con una
lluvia de ideas de lo que quieres hacer
porque podrás hacerlo muy pronto en
primer lugar vamos a retroceder un poco
y aclarar algunos términos que es
exactamente la web
bueno como ya dije es un montón de
computadoras conectadas que tienen
sitios web cuando una computadora está
conectada a la web y está mostrando un
sitio web decimos que esa computadora es
un servidor porque está dando el
servicio del sitio web
un sitio web se escribe usando tres
lenguajes html para marcar el contenido
del sitio web css para estilizar lo
javascript para hacerlo interactivo
cómo es que usuarios como tú pueden ver
esos sitios web
bueno usan aplicaciones para navegar en
sitios web como chrome firefox o
internet explorer a estas aplicaciones
las llamamos navegadores los navegadores
tratan de mostrar los sitios web de la
misma manera pero tienen sus diferencias
por lo que algunas veces decimos oops
hay un error en este navegador
intentemos con otro qué navegador estás
usando ahora bueno
debes estar usando el navegador de
alguno de estos dispositivos laptop
teléfono tableta o televisión
inteligente ya estos dispositivos los
llamamos clientes los clientes pueden
ser muy diferentes algunos son más
pequeños que otros algunos tienen
pantalla táctil otros tienen teclados
algunos son blanco y negro así que los
sitios web deben funcionar bien para
muchos tipos de clientes que cliente
estás usando ahora y esta es la web en
una versión de dos minutos hay mucho más
que aprender sobre la web pero creo que
ya es hora de empezar a escribir algo de
html y css para hacer tus propias
páginas web